okay for people who are joining our
livestream we are back after a hiatus to
continue the never-ending process of
working on updates to often language so
this is language completeness and
consistency meeting and let's start off
with the aloud heads extension oh my
okay
so this already sounds scary yes right
so while you're updating I can I can
describe roughly I don't know that I
need to update I think it also updates
and this is something that you did today
no I less committed it Friday I think
certainly last week okay okay oh did I
not actually commit it that would be
maybe I need to do a tox update oh dear
I didn't actually push it out I'm sorry
okay did you want to send it to me as
email or what no that's not going to
work yeah I'll just go ahead and commit
it right now I have the window open and
you feature that is the note but I am
actually running the update right now so
is that going to club or something it
may or may not I guess we'll find out
but you'll probably have to update again
I'll just put a lock in until one of the
others done okay all right when I can
update can I update now yes all right so
you were offering to talk through what
this says while I was updating yep so
the basic issue is
there are some situations where we want
to control what heads we enter into but
there are other situations where that's
not enough for example if in dimensions
for example if you want to treat
symmetrized array and quantity array at
the same level as both you know the same
head as a list type head so this is so
drop has proposed extending the syntax
to say not only are these both heads we
can enter into but these heads should be
considered as exactly the same and so
you see that feature is note and then
there's an example below to clarify that
in scope okay treat them so you see in
the inner level we have GNH and just
because you can enter G and H we doesn't
mean they're the same head for making it
a rectangular expression mm-hm
I see so but where else is allowed heads
used it's basically dimensions and array
depth I mean they're there well we also
do it in total I don't know that this
will a in total right total doesn't care
about being rectangular so this
extension doesn't this extension isn't
applicable to total mobile it do in that
case what will they do if you give it
it'll treat it the same as the previous
case here correct at least it should I
guess I didn't actually test that but
you know we wanted I wanted this since
that's reviewed before I finalize the
code review so yes this weekend total
where it will not work is
Transpo's hell and yeah and why is it
loud head not something that things like
map care about I mean this is basically
I should you go in that question right
it's I mean I suppose we could we could
consider adding these to map and other
such things but let me just characterize
what allowed heads is I mean you know
could thread a multi you know multi
level thread could it have an allowed
heads option I think so do we do we have
a multi level thread I think so
internally we map thread right oh yeah
map that is a certainly a good case
that's right right now map thread
requires a list head and you know that's
been a complaint for a while that
everyone the the in the second argument
it really really wants us to be lists
and not yeah I do like your idea okay so
really what treat it's not really as the
same head it's it's effectively the same
no I understand but are the same as what
and the heads of sub-expressions into
which it may descend and the question is
what about the overarching rapper okay
so in the case of dimensions it isn't
really that isn't really the right
description because isn't it the case
here that okay so
this is saying it's not into which it's
through which a function may descend I
mean in other words because it could be
at many levels in other words in the
case of a dimensions there could be six
different levels which are randomly
absent geez yes yes okay so what's the
difference between the case where right
so in the in of one in that future iced
example treated as a matrix because G
and H are being treated as the same head
at level two whereas in right so if
they'd also be the same head if I said G
of that then it would also work G of G
of right exactly so so right so if you
actually compare with the previous
example so in the previous example
there's g and g and if you we have just
explicitly listed s g and h instead of
using all we would get that two-three
result but when there's G and H at the
same level then there it's you know it's
it's not be the fact that what you can
descend into it's what are you
considering the same at a given level I
understand I understand so they but all
means to send into anything but it means
don't do this identification I mean it
probably we're gonna need a full or
something like that to say not only do
you treat it as you know what I'm saying
not only do you I mean in that case in
the case of full it would descend then
it would if it said full it'll basically
descend all the way to atoms right
because that's the only thing that
wouldn't be in the case of all the kind
of this stopping point is when you don't
have fullness sort of rectangularity at
a given level right because because
you've got different heads at those
different levels
right but so if we allowed something
like full to mean the not the list thing
but the alternatives thing right mmm-hmm
then that would be a way right that's
getting basically the maximum that that
that all sub-expressions share down to
atoms now I assume that this is well I
mean not down in the case of in the case
dimensions it would stop because it
isn't rectangular eyes anymore
exactly okay but so the main point here
is on a given level for purposes of so
for purposes of map it couldn't really
care the the distinction between F comma
G and F or you know alternatives G yep
it doesn't really care about those right
case of the rectangularity function so
to speak that they care exactly alright
this seems okay although I recommend
also allowing the fold case yeah that's
fine that's easy enough to do okay
all right I think this is good okay I
don't know if there's anything that we
as I don't think we should say is the
same header we got to make this clearer
it's equivalent at a given level you
could you could have allow any of the H
of I at a given level no because this
says allow any of the H of I mean the
one before it says okay
at a given level allow any of the h I
allow anyone of the H I okay alright so
I think it should be at a given level
allow any one of the H I you know what I
don't want to say level because that's
um I think we need to have a separate
note for functions such as dimension
could two hours making a grinding noise
please stop for functions such as
dimensions the form
[Music]
requires that all elements at a given
level have the same head
treats let's call them
you
as interchangeable
you
something like that I don't know what do
you think of that
I've heard the same because he used same
head in the sentence below which I think
does clarify it or law sorry I'm sorry
what are you suggesting I'm suggesting
you keep that treat the H by as as the
same no that's not what I said requires
that all elements have the same head to
be the same I don't want to say as
effectively the same because that
doesn't that suggest that the evaluated
value somehow has changed
I think interchangeable would be better
that's fine all right I'm okay with this
and then we also add
for full case
here
do you agree which would be just
basically treat
heads as interchangeable is that right
oh why isn't this got a 12.1 plus tag it
just needs to be default changed
you
I mean normal expression heads but um
what is a normal expression head more
importantly what's not a normal
expression head you know what's the own
so guys I think it's something it's a
it's a decorated headdress thing
well normal expressions are the ones
that that you know the full form is
literally you know head of args and the
one exception of this case or normal we
allow things besides normal expression
is Association okay Rob you're the
implementer here what does it mean
it basically means it means expressions
which which we can descend descend into
directly via the full form and and
Association is the one exception but it
of course has its you know special
special dogma think we need to we need
to basically say this so expect to add a
few notes why don't you propose some
notes for this to clarify that makes
sense
okay fine unless you need me to write
them no I think we can write something
in terms of Adam Q it sounds good to me
all right let's go on to the next item
we can ready
okay the random number state right so
this was just a thread that came up and
right there is this internal random get
random state but I'm not sure how we
want to expose this and since Rob is the
expert on such things so block random is
so Rob can you speak to what the what
the issues are here okay with the the
issues are that that the random
generators keep a state because that was
done some while ago those are those are
actually stored as big integers as
opposed to what well there could be some
kind of numeric array that's a random
state right
and and what that is is that gives you
the the random state of the the current
so why generate the equivalent of get
random state get random state gives you
the the entire anima safe for all
generators in the whole system
what does that mean okay well if you've
if you've say say say you know the
default generator is that the CA 30
generator okay but suppose you if you've
set up some other some other state okay
so some other generator get random state
will give you the state for that
generator as well because if you switch
back to that generator with seed random
you'll want to to go back to exactly
where you were before right and I would
like to point out that according to the
documentation Dollar random state is
obsolete and has been superseded by
block random okay so this is a proposal
okay so let me understand so first point
is there is in principle a random stack
a stack of random things that that is
block random you can have nested block
randoms that define a stack of random
States correct yes okay and what this
would be about is explicitly storing a
value for the purposes of building your
own you know random state maintenance
system correct correct
okay so set random state seems like a
tough thing to implement because I mean
if I say essentially dollar random state
equals 17 is that again is that does
that guarantee that it is actually an
allowable possible state for the random
just randomness system no
okay well what does set random state do
right now I think that random state does
have some some checking I honestly don't
don't remember how much how much
checking it has okay well so I always
needed
I believe get render settings it wants
something that looks like the output of
get random state okay
and so right now there is a dollar annum
state which is bizarrely just an integer
but it could be an opaque random state
object correct sure I I mean I think
that would be some sort of backward
incompatibility and not sure how serious
it would be why is it a backward
incompatibility
well because Staller random state is I
mean if you are proposing to literally
reuse dollar a random state that yes but
I mean the only incompatibility would be
if somebody took dollar a random state
and used the bits and the integer to do
something mm-hmm right and it's been
obsolete for five to ten years now as
well yeah since v6 so that's like twelve
years so right and I find it curious
that I don't see the integer that's
output by a dollar random state in the
output of get random state so are these
just two completely separate systems or
by the way Brian could we please fix the
stupid misalignment the alignment issue
yeah that's right eighteen times and I
mean crazy the weird thing is if you
actually click that triangle it realigns
it's a it's a caching as a graphics
caching issue I think it realigned right
actually got bigger just also weird yeah
it's
the dollar random state is only for the
legacy the legacy pre version six random
generators okay I see for the thing
called random so this is deeply you know
this is deeply deprecated yep mm-hmm
okay all right so we could reuse it if
we wanted to okay so the concept would
be to have a random state object that is
Dollar random state later perhaps dollar
block random state just for clarity that
this is a new thing that maybe maybe but
okay but anyway so the basic point is
that that gives you the were you to call
random integer right now what state
object would it use and by wrapping it
in a random state object we could say we
could say seed random random state
object presumably is that right yes in
other words saying Dollar random state
equals what does seed random return wow
it returns nothing
hmm interesting
what about having it return a random
state object they could do yeah yeah I I
don't see any problem with that
I mean I could imagine this code where
people have that on a separate line but
so long as the random state object is
attractive-looking
I don't think anybody's gonna be upset
by the fact that it well there's some
there there's there's there there is
some cost in instantiating that the
random state object I see
well couldn't we have it be lazy somehow
no because it could get saved in a
notebook but seed random what would see
random return if it didn't return a
random state object what is the
difference okay so to me an obvious
thing would be seed random of an integer
returns a random state object seed
random of that random state object is
equivalent to typing seed random of the
integer do you agree yes that should be
that should be equivalent I'm not sure
I'm not sure what you get by having
gained out of having seed ran and
returned around state object well we
don't get other thing um now what about
with block random what it would have
block random were to set an
initialization yeah if it had a two
argument form that was block random of a
random state object comma X / you see
what I'm saying yeah or even a kind of
any interesting form would be a block
random of a seed comma X / see what I'm
saying so we already have a seeding
option for block random right random
seeding don't we yeah okay fine but this
might be a syntactic alternative to
random seating because random seeding is
something that happens in other
functions but random seeding would then
be allowed to take a random state object
right and the whole point is that you
could recover what would be the point
here so Dollar random State would give
you the random state object at that
moment in time so that you could go back
and recover that right right right and
they said you know as an argument the
seed random or there's a possible value
for the random seating option I mean
that's that's
same the same level of difficulty I mean
it's just another way of doing women did
that work and what's the difference
between generate symmetric-key okay oh I
don't know I mean that the conversion
from string to to integer is you know
some some legacy thing that we kept
exactly the same as it was before for
backward compatibility
okay what about a general expression I
believe a general expression no yeah I
don't think so either
yeah okay generate does this work what
the heck is that
do you understand that error the thing
is expecting bits oh I see but yeah by
its existence
that's wild and wooly here's a question
what is the relationship between the
random seeding stuff and
cryptographically secure seeding because
one could imagine some key derivation
function being run I don't know what in
other words if you're using this to
generate it depends what you you know
what you're using the randomness for you
see what I'm saying so we need to make
sure that the key there at key derive
which is the key derivation function
that it what it root what does it call
what is it called wouldn't it generate
it is a derived key yeah derived key is
what we're trying to get out generate
derived key okay so
right I mean III should point out that
my guess is I mean I don't know the
internals of the cryptographic functions
but my guess is that they are treating
the string as some sort of utf-8 object
now because of backward compatibility
the way strings are created by seed
random is if they only contain plane 0
unicode create an integer based 250 base
you know 65535 out of those code points
and use that to seed the random you know
seed random otherwise I think we don't
remember if we switch the utf-8 or if we
blow it up into you know a base 2 to the
32 you know you see a sort of thing
let's let's find out but but the point
that I'm making is that derived key
should dovetail and we should also make
sure that we actually in seed random and
things like that that we quite too
derived key and vice versa ok
should I make those changes not sure I
mean I think seed random is the place
where we should be this is the place
where we should point to generate
derived key gosh I can't remember for
some reason I've just forgotten ctrl
shift come on what is that what is new
you yeah my gosh I go away for five
weeks or something altogether and I
already forget that ok generate derived
key
I think that's relevant there and then
from generate derived key
we want to point to seed random now okay
but otherwise somebody has got a lot of
background noise I mean a lot of just
noise it's how it might be you now we
don't know the noise is gone away okay
alright now there's not a lot of noise
around me but no no no it's fine okay it
wasn't you okay umm no it's perfect okay
all right so so again let's make sure
that seed random can eat some other
foods okay including derived key and so
on make sense
mm-hmm I think it should also be able to
eat hashes and I don't mean hash browns
or anything like that but you understand
what I mean the output of hash should be
able to be fed as something to seed
random make sense right I mean most
outputs well right most outputs are
either strings or byte arrays or byte
arrays oh yes they're right it can also
be integers so maybe byte arrays are the
one thing it doesn't understand okay you
know Brian from our live stream lost a
good question how would Hardware
generated seeds be supported and for
example um these physically what are
they called PFC is well they called
physical the heck are those things well
okay so this Hardware generated seats
what would happen man how would that
work I mean we don't right now have a
way you know that's a system call right
that goes and fetches a a hardware
generated seed I think right but we
don't currently have such a system call
so it's such a such a thing packaged as
a function no right I mean we do have
[Music]
right Vernie a link so to the extent
that any such things communicate with
the Bernier per protocol you could
that's less that's an unlikely I mean I
don't actually know you know there was a
big thing a few years ago that there
started to be you know Johnson noise
from resistors that were as accessible
from typical Intel microprocessors but I
see no I don't even know I don't know
how that's I rob do you know anything
about but when I was doing the parallel
stuff which I guess I see now is version
eight I thought about that and there was
no no clear clear way to easily do it
let's look again so there's an easy
system caller now okay
okay and if there is we might even
consider so that would be what would
that be I mean that would be a physical
that would be a a method option
effectively for what would it be
what would that be what kind of a thing
current random state clearly when you
have a physical you know when you have
something which is sort of a physical
source of randomness it has nothing to
do with the random state object right
right right
and we complet couldn't be a method
option for random integer unless there
was a special form of random state
object that says you know I'm a nan I'm
a non pseudo-random random state object
if you understand what I'm saying well
that would be for that method so you you
know you dude you'd you you'd have a new
method but should be physical noise or
something like that I don't know what
you call the method but I mean I would
think that the the random seeding would
be the right place to put this right so
random seeding goes to you know physical
noise generator of food that you know
where does it go into a random integer
well uh oh I guess yeah thank you I
don't think you put it in random integer
it goes and it goes in seed random so we
have these methods you can't which to
and that's just a different method which
would be cooled by which will be
specified I see so see random defines
both the C bit but okay look here's the
problem you might very well want it
might be an expensive thing to get a
random physical bit okay so you want to
get one of those as the seeding but then
use pseudo roundness from then on out to
get what I'm saying yeah so how would
you do that well then in that case what
you'd want to do you want to Suppan to
set up an interface so for you know
maybe as a special token for seed random
that would they would tell it get get
the seed from
from hardware or something like that I
mean we already have this automatic
which uses uses a you know combination
of the current time and and some weird
stuff to make it as different as
possible as unique as possible
this is the process ID and the current
time and stuff like that so we could
just have another token besides
automatic which says you know get it
from this hardware thing but that's the
method okay so but this is these methods
here are the forward-looking methods
that say how to generate randomness from
here on out right okay but so what
you're proposing here
it's well I think what he's proposing is
not a new method but a new first
argument right what he's proposing right
but he's proposing seed random physical
or something except that need to be a
head right the physical would need to be
a head a head which contains information
about which physical object so a it
would be distinguishable from a string
which is a valid dependent value and
we've got you know we've got device
execute we've got a you know we've got a
random device in the device framework so
arguably what this should be is just a
seed random of a device execute of some
kind of random thing I thought we had
some in the devices framework that we
have something which is a random device
like using you random or something maybe
this sounds vaguely familiar yeah I
thought that ego had implemented such a
thing why isn't there listed devices
here like there's a list of service
connections and so on Brian that would
be a question for you
yeah probably be there I mean it was
maybe under elated guides yeah I mean
hehe means there's a link up in the
title for service connect no but now I'm
really confused too because I thought
there just aren't very many devices
maybe that was why look random signal
demo okay that was what I had in mind
right but I don't even know how that I
mean this would be the simple way to do
this will be a device execute of some
some source of randomness in the outside
world who knows what it is but then it
gets to say what it is makes sense so
we're relying on the device execute
executing and returning something that
that can be fed to seed random yeah okay
I think that's the cleanest way to deal
with that and that that way that is a
first argument play in seed random
basically that factors out the physical
source of randomness from our you know
purely computational processors here
right and that could work that could
work for any any device where you read
list could give integers for example
sure but we should find out let's find
out what's involved in accessing the
hardware random generators and then you
know we should worry a little bit
whether the device framework is at
excessive overhead if we really wants to
use this in some serious way but I think
that's just okay so random state object
is what we think will store I mean it's
a little weird because not only does it
store the state of the random generator
it stores what generator it is I'm a
making sense so seed random says this is
the seed and here's the generator to use
right and it actually goes further then
it stores all the all the generators
that have been that have been that have
been seeded well that doesn't make sense
to me
oh you mean so that
yeah so if you do if you did if you do
say seed random of pointers that way
said can I pick the method option
separately in random integer independent
of receding no okay fine so in order to
change the method of the random
generator I've got to go back to seed
random to do it you have to go yeah or
exit back random right yeah that's
correct okay so I'm sorry so why does
with the random state object store the
states of all the random generator okay
so suppose I do the sequence of
following commands suppose I do see
grandma say one two three mmm
I generate some random numbers and then
I do seed random method goes to Mersenne
twister mm-hmm okay then I generate a
few random numbers okay so then if you
really want to have the full state at
the exit so it'll it'll mark at that
point the current method is being
Mersenne twister but suppose you go back
to you know method goes to extended CA
again okay you want to have exactly that
same sequence and that's the only way to
preserve that entire sequence oh so
you're saying ow
so that means that at every stage random
state object has to store whatever Wow
that's a horrifying you know as von
Neumann claimed anybody who you know
generates zero numbers in a state of sin
so to speak this is this is already you
know this is kind of exposing that right
because what it's saying is if at any
point in the session you used some
particular generator forevermore we're
going to have to carry around the state
of that generator that's really pretty
horrifying god what I'm saying because
because you're saying otherwise you
can't unroll it
yes you can't you can't unroll and since
you know it's only a tiny tiny percent
of people that actually use any other
generator it's probably not a big issue
and it's that's that's what's accepted
it's a weird I mean just think about you
know some sandboxing thing well somebody
is kind of trying to pass information
from you know this is some horrible
security issue
we are completely weird you know oh I
passed information in the random seating
system
sure that's a horrifying case let's
think about this for a second
so you say it ran for a while then you
redid the seeding why exactly should you
be allowed to rerun seed random just
with a method option I mean I know we
currently allow that to switch between
methods without breaking the sequence so
to speak you get what I'm saying in
other words you're right now allowed to
change methods but maintaining the sort
of flow of randomness get what I'm
saying yeah I mean that's where we're
getting ourselves in trouble does
anybody care about that I mean I think
precursor to block random I would say
block random would deal with that now by
the way random seeding can't specify a
method for randomness unless you went
through random state object correct and
I think it's also weird that seed random
doesn't return a random state object and
if it was not the case there to go back
and find all these previous sort of
legacy random States then there will be
no issue with instantiating the the
random state object correct so there's
there's there's some cost to it we have
to create we have to create well we have
to create the current form of what the
random state object is truly that comes
down lazily so if it doesn't have a
return to just disappear you know we
never create it but but if you if you
have seed ran and return it it's it's
returned right
well not if what's returned is
essentially a promise to go get it yes
we could have a desert we could have a 0
x / that that if it's put in a notebook
then I can then I can expand out or if
you say x equals seed random it's got to
expand as well but yeah I mean it's
essentially a delayed value thing well
that wouldn't even have to expand okay
that that that could be done I mean
that's pretty heavy mechanism for for a
small part of the system but but it can
be is it complicated really to do that
don't we have a million other things
that do the same thing
no our system has improved for that but
it could still be improved a bit further
okay but let's come back um why don't
you guys think through this question of
whether we really need the re method Eng
of random numbers as opposed to
reseeding okay what I'm saying
whether now that we have block random do
we need real method Inge okay well
that's do you understand what I mean by
that but the whole block random method
the whole Bach random seeding thing
works through seed random you mean
implementation way yes oh who cares I
mean you can make that work that's not
the issue like random has its own way of
working what we care about here is what
does seed random actually do and how do
you return a random state object from
seed random right block random is simply
returning the random system to the state
before the block round before block
random was called right so that's just
gonna go on doing that the question is
if you explicitly call seed random do I
need to repeat what I was just said we
got reseeding and we've got Rima ding
did you get what I'm saying right okay
do we care about re method in with seed
random I mean I think that's that's
that's how we've documented that that
people can change them now house I mean
listen to what I'm saying I'm saying can
you remarry seeding get what I'm saying
you can clearly remember nota mattock
method era or whatever the question is
does changing the method reseed the
random number generator or not no does
it keep I understand that it doesn't
right now I understand that I understand
that's implementational e how block
random works what I'm asking is does
anybody care about the fact that re
changing the method doesn't reseed the
generator I don't think they care
because without random state object or
block random they can't recut return to
the previous thing anyway
you'll find so we could break it dislike
a lot right so can you please just think
this through and not in this meeting
just to make sure that we're not missing
something here okay so my proposal is we
disallow that seed random returns a
random state object okay and and could
also be fed a random state object so
could block random be fed a random state
object so could random seed in be fed a
random state object and that's kind of
where we're at I think also that these
various cryptographic functions should
be able to be fed random state objects
and the seeding functions should be able
to be fed the output of the
cryptographic functions make sense I
don't know that's not clear to me they
don't know that there is any in this
meaning we can really speak to that okay
I'm pretty sure it's right so let's
assume it's right and if it's wrong you
can tell me it's wrong all right we need
to continue this meeting because we need
to just cover some of these other things
here quickly
okay tables in documentation okay this
is something I'm I care about here um
okay so the issue is right now if I want
to get Brian this is for you if I want
to just get that list do you see what
I'm saying there's no easy way to get
that list I propose that it becomes a
resource data object in the data
repository and that you figure out a way
to you know maybe it's a manual thing
because they may not be it may not be
easy to keep them that we just simply
put a note for example in here we will
put a note saying this table is
available as resource data of whatever
you see what I'm saying yeah yeah so
does the table include both columns just
a left-hand column it will be both
columns I think
why not and if you want because because
many uses of this you'll end up one
thing you know a labeling you know you
want to put the labels from the right
hand side it might even have another
column in it as well right I mean
they're that sort of in in terms of
automating right I mean we have two
columns we have three columns we have
the three column image style which write
one of the columns is a image rather
that's really right that the woods
simplified should be oh I see that
simplified Chinese yeah I get it okay
sorry please continue so J mean just in
terms of automating I'm not sure how are
to me the bull this is and you know
having Brian go through six thousand ref
pages solution I yeah I think the I
think this would be a thing that we find
specific pages that we want to do this
for I don't think we would I think 50 of
them okay it might even that many yeah
yeah there why there are things like
lists of instruments for various sound
functions and things like that yeah
there are no dummies big tables that
exactly I'll tell you where you're also
keep keeping this stuff is in the
autocomplete her write that table must
have found its way into the autocomplete
er so whenever a table goes in the
autocomplete system then that's a key
that you want to consider it as a
resource object well maybe but it's the
autocomplete or doesn't care if you have
one thing or 50 things if there's any if
it's one thing wrong it seems silly to
write and the idle computer only knows
about the left-hand column no no I
understand it I'm simply saying for your
purposes of tagging these things looking
at where you've got autocomplete uh
things that would be um I think the
places where we have autocomplete as
much I mean if you're talking about
fifty pages I mean no I understand I'm
simply trying to get away for Brian to
help you know to get a start on the
course yeah yeah I I get what you're
saying and then that then that makes
some sense I have to talk to Sherlock
okay enough of these things are
hard-coded into the it doesn't really
matter what do ya I mean how you get it
I don't care but but why don't you start
exposing the places where we need this
and then they'll simply be a note right
after the table that says the table is
available computable version of the
table is available in blah blah blah
place makes sound yeah yeah umm yeah
Ethan on the livestream is commenting on
the value of having more of the
documentation be computable I agree and
that's an interesting thing to think
about
I mean Watson language data could
potentially have something like this -
that was my suggestion what would it be
what would that be it would be a
property for this particular function
maybe I'm not sure what the generic name
for it would be well I think it would be
string values it would be something like
an associate string values as an
association and then the elements of the
Association would be things like in this
case you know numeric systems or
something so that the keys in the
Association would need to be manually
input probably as numeric systems is
going to be you know maybe this and one
other page it would be hard to come up
with a set of keys that we could make
these associations where that would be
yeah while we're on the subject of
completions and notes tables I would
like to I keep complaining about the
fact that the thing that allows you to
modify edit mod info no not added mod
info the what is it called edit the
thing that allows you to edit the the
other completion list generated you know
is horribly broken and 90% of the time I
just inform at the cell and manually
edit things and you know because it's so
hard to edit Tom just keeps going and
manually copying things until you you
know to get repo for code assist which
is just
a sustainable way to do this I mean you
really should be trying to make it more
automated from the documentation to get
the completions and rather than less so
and it just doesn't seem to be a
priority so I think it should be a
priority noted well well I guess the
real question is what does Stephen think
no I agree I think I think we should
make it as streamlined and automated as
possible okay and I think that's
important and I think that you know I'm
sort of fed up with finding these silly
bugs where I think some things don't
autocomplete mm-hmm I mean there there's
we're never gonna be able to take the
authors completely out of the loop I
agree with I agree with both of you but
there's always going to have to be some
human element tagging these things sure
that you know right now the obstacle is
the the obstacles are very high so I
mean from our live stream is talking
about the auto completion of string
option values which I agree is I mean
actually not just option value it's
things and associations that are I mean
there's a there's a question and how
much should we not get is a question if
you look at examples in the
documentation and you ask the question
for anything which is a literal as in a
a defined by the system thing a string a
symbol name whatever which of them
autocomplete to get what I'm saying now
what stages if we if we simply looked at
all documentation and we said let's take
every string in the input and the
documentation and break it at every
possible point does it autocomplete you
go but I'm asking burn you're saying I
mean obviously you don't mean just user
supplied junk strings no I don't mean
that I mean selectors that's why I said
that's why I said literals yeah well
okay fine right so I mean the question
would be if you simply take every
example in the document
break it at every point is there an auto
completion from that point and if not
why not because this is something I mean
I hadn't really thought about this
before but but you know I keep on
reporting autocomplete bugs right and
that's silly
right I mean we need some way to
automate so I guess this is turning into
a bit of a John Folse question of you
know doing the equivalent of hitting
command K after every comma to see if
other completions come up right sort of
programmatically test things that way
which you know I agree would be a
worthwhile test I just don't know how to
implement that but maybe maybe John we
can ask John and see if he but I would
love to have tests like that because
yeah because you know every now and then
I discover you know either missing
things or things I used to complete you
know share drop change something and
suddenly you know listen so QA needs to
I hadn't thought of this idea before but
QA needs to do something with this
mm-hmm
okay and meanwhile Brian as our first
step in making documentation more
computable Brian is going to try and
identify some of these things whether it
goes into well from language data we can
talk about that later once we see what
they are yeah
okay let's very quickly go through the
last two here right so let me just say
that between looping busy with Wolfram
Alpha notebook Edition and me being busy
with notarization we actually haven't
other developed a proposal so it might
be worth just thumping large objects
till next time but okay I mean okay so
but that's a system that's something
where where does the short happen
basically where does a short happen and
how do we still make it accessible to
the user if they want it is the basic
you know that idea you know worms its
way back into short itself because it's
the same question to my mind it's the
same thing that we're now doing with a
lot of things from audio to data set and
so on it's like do you store it in the
notebook or not I mean in other words
let's say you had a short you use short
in a notebook and it gave you a
shortened version of something then you
come back a year later and you say you
know oh I want to see more details all
right is it a tough luck situation or
not yeah yes well okay but listen listen
that's the same thing as we get with
giant data sets with giant audio and so
on where we now have this this framework
where we say you know store a notebook
or don't see what I'm saying right but I
mean yes I mean this has messages have
added additional complexities right
because it's not you're not necessarily
generating the annoy sort itself I'm
talking about the fact that somebody has
something in a notebook that says short
and they I think it's useful to give
them the option is it just short for
your current purposes or do you always
want to short it so to speak
mm-hmm right and I think that's exactly
the same story as the audio objects and
so on mm-hmm so I recommend that that
this thing that some part of this
becomes part of the general discussion
of short but let's wait for your
proposal for the rest of it okay okay
this last one about Samba shares right
so this is something you said you want
to discuss and everybody was sort of
staring confused at each other so I'm
like okay well since nobody seems to
know what you're getting at we'll just
discuss it in LCC and go from there fine
I mean I okay so I don't necessarily
understand it myself all right so this
is this is something where I have files
that so so when I use Mac OS mm-hmm I've
got a a Samba mount point for I mean
honestly if my desktop machine doesn't
make any difference because it mounts at
a boot time but like for my laptop's
this thing I have to you know maybe I'm
doing something goofy here but you know
if I'm gonna use this I have to
explicitly mount it mm-hmm
because I don't leave it mounted by
default because it's going over the
network and it will be crazy etc etc etc
great okay so my question is in Wolfram
language do we want you know don't we
want a programmatic way to do that mount
because otherwise I have to go out to
the operating system let's say I want to
access a file that's on my samba now
under whatever it's called right
wouldn't it be nice if I could
programmatically request that and given
that we now have system keychain support
if there is an authentication that needs
to happen at that to access that to
mount that filesystem we could just do
that okay
that was my point okay so I guess my
well I'm laying I'm going to give you
one of my nicer responses which is I
don't think that's crazy okay it's
better than I expected okay yeah I'm not
sure okay my answer is I'm not sure is
all right then there was this thing
about URL read that just means that it
is accessible using URL read nothing
more than that what success the Samba
mount yeah I mean it's a network
protocol so obviously it is available
through URL read nothing more you're
saying that there is a version of it I
mean I don't know what to you know if I
bring it up like I don't even know what
what to do here I'm gonna show yeah I
mean it's all kinds of weird Mountie
things here so multi thing is different
there you can just access copy file and
whatever but
what if it is not mounted no I
understand that's what I'm asking so is
it the case so if I go to so that's the
URL basically and you're telling me that
if I go to that URL with the appropriate
authentication I will be able to get to
those files
is that correct without quotes mounting
it yes and the value of mounting it is
what that it shows up in the finder then
is just a local Drive that's it right so
once it's mounted right it's a it's a
you know it appear it's accessible to
everything and appears on the local file
system right under the hood is it still
doing sort of some Network requests yes
it must be right so it's not faster if
it's mounted or anything like that is it
no it shouldn't be education work does
the authentication don't have to
authenticate every time if I do the
explicit URL read it should well we
could work on caching it but I I mean
that could be solved right yeah so right
the point is if you mount it then you
only need to authenticate once and then
it everything you know everything
appears is a local file if you just do
you know a copy file or using some URL
read the thing then each time you access
a file that will need to relocate yeah
that's what I was thinking yes yes the
value to this mounting idea right yeah
and the I mean the point with URL read
is that you know right now it returns an
HTTP I mean this isn't sort of
explicitly documented but effectively
what it returns is a HTTP response
object which if we're using the SMB
protocol really doesn't make any sense
so we need to see and think some about
what or saw a URL execute may think is
the one you execute with an SMB
no it's URL lead that returns your every
yes object your execute just does board
you know returns the body right so URL
read quickest return the string because
that's what we do for FTP oh it is yeah
okay so so is documented in a wonky way
is all there is to it I mean what do you
mean the URL read you're saying URL read
has a different case for other than HTTP
yeah we just returned a strength because
we don't know what to do is that instead
documented somewhere yeah obviously not
oh okay because I mean how it would look
ridiculous if we returned an HTTP
response for FTP right okay so hold on
so what we've exposed here is two issues
one issue is what does URL redo on a non
HTTP so URL right yes
I mean arguably we should have a more
generic response well yes it should
always have had been that way but I'm
not going to get angry with it but it
should have written by turi
I don't know if we had byte array when
URL read was I don't think it should
return by two right that's okay fine I
think it's great what it returns I think
it's great that it returns an object I
think the is okay I mean I have
objections to that because when you do
you are a read of an URL and you get an
object then you have to figure out what
to do with the object rather than just
having some data with you but that's
what the data is it depends where the
data is useful well if somebody is
reading an HTTP why don't we return the
HTML because that's what people are
interested in most of the body okay
that's not it's not the headers for
example they might also want the headers
okay okay
I think what we have is fine I mean I
think what we what we are effectively
returning is an associate but I mean I
don't know what FTP returns I don't know
whether it just returns the content body
or I'm sure FTP also returns status
codes and things it does as a part of
headers yes it does okay so then it
really needs a URL response basically of
some kind yes so so okay so do we have
an FTP server somewhere so you can show
us what this actually looks like when we
because you're claiming that URL read as
is can read from an FTP let me just
check the bugs oh actually there is but
it may require password or something is
the LDAP stuff no we're not gonna do
that
l-dub let's just find a random FTP
server out on the web um let's see I
mean there's got to be some FTP for some
government site let's see here we go
which one did you send it yeah I am
sending you could try that is a group
chat or I sent it to you directly no I
got it okay what the heck is that I've
no idea what that is
so
let's just see whether we can find a
random thing out on the web but that is
a this is very confusing this claims to
be an FTP server yet it presents itself
as a web server that's super confusing
it's one of these cases I wonder if
somebody on our live stream knows that
an a random FTP server um could you not
type in our air please using a headset I
don't I don't think it's you
we've got to have I was crazy that we
can't find an FTP server okay in any
case you're saying that the ftp server
will simply I mean I know the FTP server
cuz I remember from using FTP for
millions of years ago that it returns
all kinds of status codes right yes yes
it does I mean I'm just finding a random
page on the web this is what it looks
like right TP blah blah blah blah give a
password so it is not the case that
returning a string is the right thing to
do
right and it's also state-based so that
that is that will make things more
interesting but okay but so so what
you're telling me is that we've not done
a good job um ah terrific
this is an FTP server random government
FTP server thank you to Brian okay
whatever this is fire incident data okay
terrific let's see how we get to some of
it what is this oh that's an FTP site
okay so this is that is so so bizarrely
confusing what this is doing so this is
saying so if I now just do a URL read of
that FTP is assuming could you do
enthalpy colon forward slash forward
slash
and why don't you actually go to one of
the [ __ ] you'll have to grab the file
because see uh it's hard to justify what
protocol you're using so as long as it's
a file it will work if it's a folder it
won't okay to go about to get okay so so
you're saying if I go to this is it a
file it's an empty directory so great I
thought I was gonna get a photograph of
some fire somewhere who knows yeah try
one of those okay man how do I do I
replace that by FTP yeah great okay so
maybe they don't have an FTP server
anymore despite their claims um okay
oh there's another FTP server somebody
is providing here okay it's a speed test
FTP server all right let's try this one
now it has to be yeah see you'll get
that problems because what is doing in
the under the hood is assuming as HTTP
so is setting some requests okay so in
fact it doesn't work so URL read in fact
does not work with FTP yeah it does as
long as it's a file so that's not a file
that's a server address so it has to do
an actual file so as you saw before if I
go to if I go to a terminal yeah and I
start FTP is that right mm-hmm
Stephan
add the slash 300 or sorry 3mb cotton
caps that's it to the URL so in the end
of 12 yeah @ / 3 MB and caps that's at
lower case yeah ok well then I think URL
read is just broken because that that's
certainly yeah that's a bug because what
version are you using pretty sure I
fixed okay no this needs to be fixed
okay we'll look FTP support I mean what
other protocols so so look SM okay what
you were basically saying is that URL
read is really set up for HTTP stuff and
it does fine for that but these other
protocols of which FTP is one obvious
one SMB is another one are not really
properly supported here yes that is
correct so we should look into what it
would take to understand how to support
these um yeah I mean we've had this
discussion before but we it never went
anywhere not in terms of actionable
items now I understand an acrylic Nomad
on our live stream is commenting about
about the way that you actually use FTP
in this sequential fashion yeah I mean I
agree it's not and the fact that we
can't even find any FTP servers on the
web makes it not as exciting to you know
to support FTP um but this mounting and
SMB business is a different thing
because that's still alive and well I
mean I we should ask the Stewart and
people like that in the data feeds group
whether we're still using FTP to get
data from who knows where you know where
NORAD or the FAA or whatever else they
may very well still be using FTP let's
find out consumer
ask Stuart please that question and also
every wait wait wait I want to check
that somebody can actually do that
before we move on okay sorry go ahead
for him I was saying that SFTP is also
being used I just had a query about that
where our solutions group was quite
interested in having that work okay fine
let's get a sense of what is being what
is being done with it whether it is a
one-shot use or whether it's some kind
of exploratory use that involves old you
know as a chronic Nomad says um you know
nineteen eighty cents stuff right so by
the way I just tried this in eleven
three and and it works so and yes what
you get is just a string out or in those
thirteen okay so um I I would I just
want to make a comment it could be like
IMAP links or FTP is very similar to
IMAP where you have state-based protocol
is the ping-pong protocol where you you
do CD and I just think this is one of
these why the heck could we support it
exactly that's what it is and so the
fact that we have something where you
can just get files that's good enough so
well I think that's good enough okay so
on our live stream Brian mentions
supporting non s mb file systems across
operating systems and the mounting of
those yeah I think that's worth looking
at right I don't know whether there is
an operating system mount command that I
mean there used to be back in the day in
UNIX there was just a mount command I
have no idea how that relates to us and
B or how it relates to you know it still
exists in in Mac OS and Linux I don't
know about em you know iOS or Android is
it a quotas mount can mount Mountain SMB
file system or not it should be able to
it just
you need to you know specify the type
that's right edited in 1994 yeah but
it's better it's been updated
I mean mount has been updated Mount
understands AP FS and things I mean so
maybe they haven't bothered to update
the man page but and and even if even if
it's not directly through mount I mean
I'm sure there's there are you know
other commands that can be used all
right look let's go find out and let's
see whether this is something that's
worth dealing with I think it is because
I think it's useful you know in
certainly in my own work because I have
a network you know network file system
out there I would certainly use it um
okay and meanwhile this whole question
about other protocols than HTTP let's
let's hear about that again in another
meeting and talk about what what support
if any we want to have for those and it
sounds like there's a bug for for him
with FTP right now okay I will address
that okay okay thanks horrific thanks
all thanks to focus on the live stream
talk to y'all soon Hey